for the EU the dairy market is extremely  important that you is world's leading  exporter of many dairy products like  milk butter or cheese every year 160  million tons of milk is produced 15% of  EU egra cultural output milk is produced  in every EU Member State the main  producers are Germany France the United  Kingdom Poland the Netherlands and Italy  which together account for almost  seventy percent of the EU production  dairy sector is currently currently  experiencing a prolonged market  disturbance and this is mainly due to a  gap between demand and supply the price  is affected by this mismatch obviously  and in some Member States this has gone  even below the production costs and this  is the reason why farmers are in  distress in some of our member states